[Música]
cuatro años en el poder cumplió el
presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel López
Obrador y lo celebró marchando junto a
sus seguidores y defendiendo tanto su
gestión de gobierno como su propuesta de
reforma electoral
el consejo electoral Nacional de Cuba
extendió el horario para votar en las
elecciones municipales en medio de la
alta absorción a las 2 de la tarde hora
local la participación era casi un 20%
menos que la que había para la misma
hora en los comicios locales de 2017
y el partido más esperado de la jornada
de hoy en el mundial quedó en empate
pues tanto España como Alemania metieron
un gol cada uno mientras que Canadá
quedó eliminado tras perder ante Croacia
4 a 0 Tenemos reporte desde
Bienvenidos a las noticias de France 24
yo soy María Clara calle y es un placer
acompañarlos comenzamos en México hoy el
presidente de Andrés Manuel López
Obrador cumplió cuatro años en el poder
para celebrarlo organizó una marcha en
el centro de la capital Ciudad de México
esto de Cara a las elecciones generales
de 2024 y en un momento en el que el
congreso debate la polémica reforma
electoral impulsada por el maldad
mandatario los detalles con Gabriel
cochán una salida entre sus seguidores
para celebrar su cuarto año en el poder
el presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel
López Obrador estuvo este domingo en las
calles de la Ciudad de México la
manifestación organizada por el
presidente mismo reunió a miles de en el
centro de la ciudad cuando él nos hasta
en los momentos más difíciles de la
pandemia hemos garantizado que a la
gente no le falte lo básico no ha habido
hambre ni por eso se ha mantenido la paz
y ha permanecido encendida la llama de
la esperanza según varias encuestas el
presidente tiene una tasa de popularidad
alta con un 60% de aprobación sabemos
que no ha sido muy fácil faltan muchos
por hacer pero estamos muy contentos de
que el presidente ha cumplido con la
mayoría de sus compromisos la marcha
hace yo solo unos días después de otra
movilización en la cual participaron
miles de opositores para protestar
contra la polémica propuesta de reforma
electoral en abril el presidente
presentó un proyecto de reforma del
Instituto Nacional electoral el órgano
autónomo que organiza las elecciones en
México la reforma que requiere el apoyo
de al menos dos tercios parlamentó
podría eliminar varias instituciones
importantes y concentrar la Organización
de las elecciones en manos del partido
gobernante la oposición denuncia un
riesgo para la democracia y algunos
Incluso acusan el presidente de querer
mantenerse en el poder Aunque López
Obrador prometió que no se presentará a
su reelección México celebrará
elecciones generales en 2024 según la
Constitución el presidente puede ejercer
un solo mandato más de 8 millones de
cubanos estaban llamados a participar en
las elecciones municipales hoy para
elegir a más de 12.000 delegados la
votación se dio en medio de una fuerte
Ascensión convocada por los opositores
del gobierno de Miguel Díaz canel el
llamado Parece que fue escuchado Pues a
las 2 de la tarde solo había participado
el 53% del padrón electoral esto es un
19% menos que la participación de 2017
la autoridad electoral cubana respondió
extendiendo el horario hasta las 7 de la
noche hora local veamos
en Cuba también votan este domingo en
concreto para sus elecciones municipales
el presidente Miguel Díaz canel
reivindicó la celebración de los
comicios Pues eso electoral
mantiene la estabilidad política
mantiene su estabilidad social
independientemente del primero de
recrudecimiento de la batalla económica
la batalla de asfixia económica que nos
están tratando de implantar para que la
población por el descontento por la
desesperanza por lo agobio de todas las
carencias vayan anhelado estallido
social que tiene el gobierno
imperial que es aplicar la lógica
imperialista en estas elecciones se
escogen los delegados que conforman las
asambleas municipales del poder popular
no pueden hacer campaña y las
nominaciones son en reuniones vecinales
donde se tiene en cuenta méritos
personales sino posiciones políticas por
lo que no tienen que pertenecer al
partido comunista entre sus funciones la
gestión directa de problemas y quejas en
las comunidades además de proponer que
el 50% de los candidatos a las asambleas
provinciales y al parlamento elección
legislativa que tendrá lugar en 2023 es
importante muy importante porque así se
representa el pueblo en
la asamblea la oposición sin embargo
había pedido a la ciudadanía la
abstención denuncian que se les ha
impedido en gran medida participar en
unas elecciones marcadas por la grave
crisis económica que vive Cuba y en
medio de su crisis económica Cuba
recibió un alivio pues china acordó
reestructurar la deuda que tiene el país
latinoamericano y proporcionar nuevos
créditos comerciales y de inversión el
ministro de economía de Cuba Alejandro
Gil agregó que el gigante asiático
además donó 100 millones de dólares para
ayudar al país a hacer frente a la
escasez de productos básicos y a la
crisis energética
y mientras China tiene ese papel en las
relaciones con Cuba internamente
enfrentan manifestaciones que no había
visto años por segunda noche consecutiva
miles de personas salieron a las calles
de ciudades principales como Beijing y
Shangai para mostrar su descontento con
las restricciones por la política de
cero covid las protestas llegan cuando
china lleva cuatro días rompiendo sus
propios récords de nuevos contagios
es Shangai y los manifestantes gritan
contra los confinamientos y contra el
presidente shigging ping la policía
responde con detenciones y lo que empezó
el sábado como una vigilia por los
muertos en un incendio en un edificio en
la región de shinyang se convirtió en
protestas contra las estrictas
restricciones por Kobe 19
es una locura creo que primero es por
shiggins el presidente debemos terminar
con su dictadura porque a él solo le
importa el mismo es por eso que mucha
gente murió por él pero ahora es una
buena noticia que muchas personas se den
cuenta que es un presidente ilegal en el
incendio murieron 10 personas Se presume
que no pudieron abandonar el edificio
por las restricciones por Kobe 19 esto
en una región de mayoría oigur es decir
musulmana contra la que hay denuncia de
vulneración de los Derechos Humanos
familiares denuncian que la asistencia
llegó demasiado tarde
vas a tener los primeros los huigures
siempre están siendo perseguidos por el
gobierno chino de una forma u otra y
odio eso
las protestas se van expandiendo por
todo el país un fenómeno poco común en
China esto es Beijing en la prestigiosa
universidad singua los estudiantes
cantaron proclamas por un estado de
derecho democrático y por la libertad de
expresión son las consecuencias del
hartazgo después de casi tres años de
confinamientos en China por el covid-19
que coincide con los días en los que el
país está registrando el mayor número de
casos desde el inicio de la pandemia
ahora hagamos un breve repaso de algunos
desastres naturales que han ocurrido en
el mundo y comenzamos en Libia porque
las Fuertes lluvias de este domingo en
la capital trípoli hicieron que varias
de las vías principales se inundarán por
lo que la oficina de asuntos de tráfico
pidió a los conductores que tomaran
precauciones por su parte el Centro
Meteorológico Nacional estima que habrá
tormentas eléctricas en el norte del
país
14 personas murieron en la capital de
Camerún mientras estaban en un funeral
los asistentes estaban en una cancha de
fútbol cuando un pedazo de tierra de 20
metros de altura se desprendió y les
cayó encima
y en la isla italiana subieron a siete
los muertos por los torrenciales cinco
personas siguen desaparecidas y los
buzos continúan buscando en las aguas al
frente de la costa el deslizamiento de
tierra se produjo el sábado desde la
montaña más alta de la isla en la ciudad
de casimiquiolaterra
y antes de terminar Vamos hasta doha
donde nuestro enviado especial Juan
pupiales nos envió un resumen de los
partidos más importantes de la jornada
buen partido de que vivimos aquí en el
estadio albate entre España y Alemania
empate a uno entre dos elecciones que
llegaron con caras muy distintas España
que venía de golear 7 a 0 a Costa Rica
mientras que los germanos venían de caer
contra Japón con los Hermanos hubo dos
cambios no estuvo havers el delantero ni
tampoco el defensa explotenberg en su
lugar ingresaron querer y león
goretteska de la mano sobre todo de
hongoresca jugador del Bayern de Múnich
la selección germana presionó muchísimo
y molestó mucho la salida de España
desde atrás España no pudo dominar el
balón a su antojo Como hizo contra Costa
Rica sin embargo el equipo dirigido por
Luis Enrique supo mantener su identidad
y así llegó ese primer gol al minuto 60
lo hizo Álvaro morata quien volvió a
salir desde el banquillo y volvió a
marcar sin embargo Alemania hizo cambios
dio entrada por fin al heroízame que
tuvo sus primeros minutos en esta copa
mundo de la mano de ese refresco llegó
el tanto de la igualdad sobre el minuto
83 lo hizo nicklas fullrock el delantero
del werder bremen que amplía las
opciones de su selección de Cara a la la
última jornada previamente Costa Rica
había dado la campanada de la jornada la
imponerse a Japón con 1 a 0 así las
cosas España termina esta segunda fecha
como líder de grupo los españoles que
necesitan un empate contra Japón para
avanzar para asegurar ese pase a octavos
de final mientras que Costa Rica depende
de ella misma contra Alemania para
seguir soñando en este mundial de Qatar
2022 hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]